[Music]
all right hello everybody we're here
with um
another lecture this time we're going to
be talking about um just some modern
trends in open opening studies
and i've noticed that over the past
maybe
five years or so maybe 10 at most
the way that top level players are
approaching the opening has has changed
dramatically
remember like when i was a kid and and
sort of first starting out
in the late 90s
it seemed like there were these players
that were just married
to their openings like okay these guys
would play the night or against king
pond they would play the king's indian
or the groomfeld against queen pond
and
what determined your success or failure
in the opening was okay how far into the
opening are you able to
just sort of study memorize understand
and like it was these uh you you had to
be familiar with typical end games and
typical tactical themes so
it was really kind of a
length
your success was determined by the
amount of moves that you knew and that's
not really what's what's going on now i
think that approach has been tapped out
and you rarely see players um
sticking to that i would say probably
the one the holdout is mvl maxine bashir
lagrav he still plays his night orf and
his groomfeld religiously but he's been
struggling a lot over the past few years
i mean
he used to be one of the most successful
players with the najdorf and i can't
remember the last time he won a night or
honestly
in fact there was this vikanze i think
it wasn't last year maybe it was the
year before
where he played like three night orbs
back to back to back and lost them back
to back to back and it was just like you
got to change something man because it
wasn't like he was winning and blundered
he just got crushed every game
so
what does
opening preparation entail today
well if you look at some of the most
popular openings right now
maybe to the
disappointment of
many fans that enjoy you know crazy
tactical games i mean what would be the
the openings that stand out to you like
that you just see most commonly in
practice
anybody care to take a shot
okay so you see the groomfeld quite
often
anything else
i mean there's
i would say the groomfeld if not for
something that white can do to kind of
avoid the groom field
what like let's say you're playing with
black
and your opponent
what would be the thing that would
bother you the most what's that thing
when you sit down you're like oh i hope
he doesn't do this thing
we all have that opening
right that bothers us that we're just
like i don't want to deal with this
today
well
for me one of them is the london right
the london
happens all the time
and uh it it gets this kind of
bad reputation
and that was the image i had of it i was
like okay the london is the lazy man's
opening it's an opening that you know
you don't have to study theory
uh it kind of just tells you where your
pieces need to go
and you know it's an unpretentious
opening you just get out of the
opening with an equal position and you
play right that was my impression of
london and i was completely wrong the
london is about so much more than that
in fact i decided to start
trying it out myself
with absolutely disastrous results so
um
that's what i wanted to share with you
guys today i wanted to talk a little bit
about the london but
to use it as an example of a much
broader thing that's going on currently
in opening theory
which is that
players are more interested in choosing
little subtleties early on in the game
right they want to outplay you or trick
you
very soon they're not looking to engage
with you in
in some kind of competition of who can
rattle off the most moves that's not
really what's going on anymore so the
london is a perfect example of that you
have the italian is another perfect
example of that
with black
you have
the caro khan is another good example of
that
[Music]
but anyway we're going to use the london
as our case study for today and i'm
gonna be using uh hold on
can you see the moves there can i like
um
do you want me to move the projector
yeah just so that the moves get
get blocked is that possible yeah i
think i'll get to it okay
so
anyway in my game this is from the
spring classic that um
that ended just a little bit over a week
ago
maybe two weeks ago where i was white
against a
player from india
a grand master named
raja
harshit and after knight f6 knight f3
d5 bishop f4 e6 we get our
basic
starting position of the london there
are many different approaches that black
can take here e6 is by no means forced
in fact
um
as as black
i would often
avoid playing e6
what's going on
he's playing games with me
i would often avoid
playing are you guys seeing this
okay it's not
like i make a move and then it's it's
like i don't i don't like your move and
it takes it back
this happened a few times with dorset
too really i don't know
maybe it's because my my file is too
loaded
um let's see if i
yeah that's 2 000 moves okay let's see
if it takes it now
no
huh
yeah the the instance that she
encountered was it was
leeches would not let her input any more
moves
that were deviations from what she had
already entered
uh-huh all right so if if i delete some
it should let me
we never solved it uh oh that's that's
promising yeah just the next night it
worked again okay it didn't seem to
matter how large the study was
interesting not good
it's not good not good so
oh remove the sink you're saying
maybe
let's see
does it take it no
so wait if i
let's say add a new chapter
will it do it there
well it seems to work here
so i'll just have to rely on my flawless
memory
for those like 2 000 variations i had to
save there
um
all right we'll see i think i can pull
it off
anyway so we'll get around to e6 in just
a moment but i was mentioning the move
c5 because if we're going to talk about
the london we might as well just do a
general overview of what's out there
now the point of c5
when you compare it to e6 is that black
is attempting to solve the problem of
this bishop in a much different way like
whenever you go e6 and d4 d5 openings
whenever you go e6 sorry
it's not like you're giving up on this
bishop and saying sorry you know i tried
you're actually planning on developing
the bishop to b7
so these are two different approaches it
really depends
where you believe the bishop is going to
have
more potential if outside the pawn chain
or inside
but
after something like knight bd2
one of black's ideas is to take on d4
and go bishop f5
so i think black is very close to
equalizing here if not for very
interesting move that white has here
which is bishop b5 so this is currently
the problem that black is facing in this
line many times because white's going to
go
95 c4 queen a4 and there's some
substantial pressure on c6
the other line that you'll probably see
a lot of games
uh being played it's the move queen b6
which historically well i mean
historically like over the past couple
of years
has been the go-to move for black and
the point is that after
d takes queen takes b2
um
[Music]
rook b1
queen c3 and bishop b5 we get a very
messy position
where it looks like white's queen side
has been completely decimated but white
has a substantial lead in development
and some very interesting ideas for
example
ideas like playing castles and e4 it
really depends what black does black has
two plans g6 which was recommended by
sam shankland i think a couple of years
ago in the course he did
for chesable very interesting move then
you have e6 but anyway
there was a very nice game played at
last year's u.s seniors
a tiebreak game between
greg kaidanov and larry christensen
where kaidano i don't know if he had
prepared the whole thing or not but he
just played this
this brilliant game with black right so
larry was playing white and kaidanov
just
masterfully uh
handled the black side and won a very
clean game
so
queen b6 is one of the key lines that's
currently like at the foreground of the
discussion
so
in this game my opponent decided to play
with the bishop inside of the pawn chain
and
now after
e3 he played bishop d6 now
i would say
that the queen b6 variation and this
variation with bishop d6 are the two
main lines
these are the if you play the london
with white these are the two lines that
you need to start with because not only
are they the most common they're also
the most critical
so
this was thought to be absolutely
um
harmless for black for many many years
in fact what would be some of
what moves could could white play here i
mean uh
what would you guys play if you had this
position with white
okay so bishop g3 by far
the most natural move any other moves
it's funny because bishop g3
is the only harmless move in the
position
and it's the
move that used to be played just
systematically
until
lanier dominguez won a brilliant game
against gada camps yada kamsky by the
way
i'm going to go out on the limb and say
he is single-handedly responsible for
revitalizing the london system i mean
after gatta made his comeback from uh
ret retirement in the mid
2000s
he came back with some really fresh
ideas i mean he would play this um
the chebanenko slav right this slab with
g6 kind of like a a hybrid between
groomfeld and slav he won many nice
games
and then he started playing the london
system
won many nice games still continues to
win
many nice games but
not many people sort of picked up with
the chebanenko slot but everybody got on
board with the london so
why is bishop g3 harmless here well
in the old days it was thought okay
black plays c5 and after c3
knight c6 normal moves
maybe
castles bishop d3 and b6
and i played this many many times with
black
my idea was well if white castles after
bishop b7
white's going to do something like
knight e5 maybe
and after queen c7 f4
and white's very close to getting
a dangerous attack on the king side
white's going to go bishop h4 queen f3
g4 and so on
but
black has a wonderful maneuver to punish
white for weakening the e4 square that
maneuver
is uh 97 and i think after queen f3
knight f5
and after bishop f2 the key move
is this
quiet retreat by the bishop
allowing the knight to come to d6 and if
you keep pushing
then i've sort of recycled all of my
pieces to really pound away at the e4
square so so this position is considered
to be
really good for black
but
something happened here right white
realized i don't have to do any of this
instead
white began experimenting with the move
e4
threatening e5
and it was thought that black could
simply play bishop e7
and now after e5 knight h5
and
once white castles black will take on g3
and have a very comfortable game
of course you don't want to take before
because then you might open up the
h-file for the rook and this would be
dangerous
but then and i remember i i was playing
uh it was one day like
three a.m
and i was just playing blitz online
and i'm like oh this guy's playing the
london
uh piece of cake
and he plays this line and he plays the
move knight g5 against me i'm like
oh
i think i just walked into something
the point being that after bishop takes
g5
queen takes h5
g6
you can see why white didn't want to
castle because white wants to create a
hook here that you can take advantage of
with h4 h5 now this does involve a pawn
sacrifice
right after c takes d4 h4 bishop h6 h5
and this position is a total mess
but you'll have to take my word for it
that this is incredibly dangerous for
black
even if you do something like this no
problem i mean white's gonna
uh
well depends what you do right if you go
bishop g7 many times white will actually
play
against the bishop on h8 white could go
like f4 knight f3
bishop h4
um if white does something like g4 g5
you're basically going to be down a
bishop for the rest of the game
so anyway
this is the current
problem
that black well
it was the problem that black was facing
until lanier dominguez sort of found a
way around it
now what he did is he said i
shouldn't hurry up
developing this knight on b8
instead i'm going to castle
and after knight bd2
i'm gonna go queen c7
and after bishop d3
i'm gonna go knight b d7
and the point is that black is fighting
for this e5 square very quickly for
example if you castle now
then
black simply goes e5
and
the london system
for all its subtleties and numerous
lines
you can boil it down to one
simple idea
whoever
wins
the battle for the e5 square is going to
win the opening battle period so
black is going to try really hard to
play e5 and white's going to try really
hard for that not to happen usually
white's going to try by playing like
knight e5 and f4 like we just saw but
this would be a perfect example
of
black realizing his opening goals
so i think
kamsky
in the position might have played
something like a4 i don't really
remember so well
but um
but he got nothing out of the opening
and he actually lost
i would say
very convincingly
that's pretty much why bishop g3 has
experienced a substantial decrease in
popularity so it was thought that okay
london is done they finally cracked the
code
but it was nowhere near uh done actually
and here white has
a couple of really interesting choices
to bishop g3
the one i played in the game knight bd2
i think is is very interesting despite
my my horrendous sort of handling of it
and the other idea and i would say very
closely related to knight bd2
in fact it often leads to transpositions
is knight e5 right a move that makes
sense if we understand how important the
e5 square is and is going to be
so
let me ask you guys a question
what do you think about this change in
the pawn structure right because this
would seem
like the obvious question after knife
bd2
okay so
we absolutely have improved our control
over e5 not just because of the pawn on
f4 but when we go bishop d3 castles and
rookie one will also have the e file
right so
i remember in the beginning people would
cringe when they would see this
structure they would say oh but double
pawns i mean these double pawns are are
untouchable right because
worst case scenario you just go g3 and
defend it and
these pawns are doing a phenomenal job
at making up for
your dark square bishop right for being
traded off so you don't even feel that
bishop gone so this i think is the kind
of pawn structure that black should try
to avoid at all costs
in fact
i was looking i remember when i was
preparing for this game
i was looking at some positions like
this for example
and it turns out that these two squares
are really ideal squares for the white
knights white's plan is going to be to
play something like c3 bishop d3 knight
beat d4 95 maybe castles queen e2 it's
like all white's pieces find beautiful
squares and the position has this
natural flow to it
so
this is really the whole point behind
knight bd2 is to try to get that pawn
structure
[Music]
knight e5
obviously kind of sidesteps
all of that
and instead
aims number one
to to really establish a firm grip over
e5 sometimes playing you know knight d2
knight df3
but also
clearing the diagonal for the queen
and preparing for a possible initiative
on the king side maybe based on h4 h5 g4
g5
so
i thought 95
was interesting but then i
i started to see
some issues with it for example
i think after castles
knight
d2
c5
c3 and queen c7 i think this was one of
the critical positions
and
one of the things i failed to grasp
during the game
were the subtleties for example
it might seem
natural to play bishop d3
but there are some cases where you you
want to delay this move and
white does have
other useful moves so if you sketch out
what white's plan is right what are all
the moves that white wants to play
obviously bishop d3 is one of them that
white might want to go h4 h5 white might
want to go queen f3 white might want to
go knight d f3
so
whenever you have a plan that involves
several moves
the hard part is deciding okay which
move should i start with and usually the
way that you're going to answer that
question
is by playing the move
that's most flexible that not only
avoids closing the door for one of the
other moves but actually
opens the door for maybe some new moves
so for example
let's say
i go bishop d3
right after bishop d3 my next moves are
going to be
maybe h4
maybe knight df3
but if i start with h4 now i'm also
introducing a new idea yes i could go
bishop d3 and knight df3 right two moves
that were already part of my plan
but i've also opened the door for my
h-pawn to keep advancing so now i've got
yet another move that's part of my plan
right so
i'm broadening my
my sketch of possible moves and that's
really what you want out of the opening
you want flexibility you want options
so
i think probably h4 here would be
the right
or the most accurate move and we're
going to see why you need to be careful
about developing the bishop to d3 too
soon so
in my game i played knight bd2
uh
black castled and we're going to see
that uh
this is going to be very similar i
played 95
and my opponent played b6
this move actually surprised me a little
bit i wasn't expecting this move i was
really just expecting black to play you
know c5 c3 and queen c7 and take it from
here
but b6 i think
um i think black is playing the same
game that i am and that's why
you see incredibly strong players
defending both sides of this position
because
there are a lot of little
subtleties or
tricks in
that that are based on your
understanding of the position rather
than your memorization of it
if you try to memorize these openings
you're going to drive yourself crazy
so
i played
um
the move bishop
d3 here
and after
c5
c3
c7
and now i played h4 and i think h4
now is actually a dubious move
so
what reason could there be
for
in one scenario playing h4 and it's
absolutely fine right a scenario where
the bishop's on f1
as opposed to the other one were the
bishops on d3 how could this possibly be
a bad thing for white
any ideas
um
d7
knight b to d7
and uh
i don't i'm not sure if i should go
knight d to f3
or if i need to take on d7 but
my initial reaction would be to play
something like this
so what would your follow-up
be
be careful because i might take this way
oh sorry
but if you take with the bishop then
you're really giving up on your dark
squares right so i could just take this
way and say okay you know
bishop pear i think
this is a dream come true for white
so that's not exactly what white is
afraid of i think white has a strong
enough grip
over e5
uh in the chat here they they're
they're right on the money
the point
is to play bishop a6
and the problem with this move i mean
the problem for white is that well you
wasted a move right by playing bishop d3
because you're probably going to have to
take on a6 anyway
so
after bishop takes a6 knight takes a6 i
think black is actually absolutely fine
here
so
okay
so you mean after this
after bishop takes knight takes yeah
like for example if i attack the knight
well the knight's just going to go back
so then
did like waste a move then
if black has to move multiple times
well i think
i don't know how useful the move queen
e2 is going to be for white
i mean usually queen e2 is useful when
the bishops on d3 to stop bishop a6
but now
that your bishop is gone okay your
queen's on e2
how are you going to continue as white
let's say you go something like h5 right
just to be consistent with your moves
and
and i
stopped the advance of your pawn with h6
i mean maybe you know you you start
uh attacking on the king side but these
can be pretty pretty tricky pretty
dangerous uh for both sides because if
g4
backfires for white you know your king's
in the center you know your position is
kind of shaky like let's say i go
knight c6
now you have to be careful because if i
go knight
d to f3
maybe black's going to go 94 and now you
have to start
watching out for for moves like f6
and if you don't have something amazing
against f6
your entire position starts to collapse
as white because it's only a matter of
time before black plays e5 now
i would say that
one of the main reasons not the only
reason that white pushes the pawn to h5
is not necessarily because of his
attacking ambitions but because
i don't know i just want to make some
kind of random move because against f6
now you're able to at least play knight
g6 so by having a pawn on h5 and forcing
the black pawn to h6
you you take the sting out of f6 at
least a little bit now this is probably
still a very good version for black
but um
but the pushing the pawn to h5 is is one
of those subtleties right it's one of
those things that's going to make
black's idea less strong than it usually
is
now
it's not like this is devastating for
white right i mean
like like you saw the game goes on
but what could white
have played here instead of h4 right in
order to argue that at least this you
know this position is still
white can still fight for an advantage
here
[Music]
yes
this is what i should have played
but i remember during the game i was
like well that's nonsense right because
black's just going to go a5 and bishop
a6
is coming next anyway
but there are some important differences
and i mean this is the bread and butter
of the london system if you play the
london system or you want to play the
london system you can never
say to yourself
oh but this is like the same as before
like pawn on a5 is going to make no
difference these kinds of moves make all
the difference in the london because now
after bishop a6 bishop takes knight
takes
having the pawn on a5
substantially weakens black's queen side
the b5 square is weak
the b6 pawn is weaker because it's not
defended by the pawn on a7
and overall
um
white can now start
to think about both sides of the board
right white can say okay i gotta i can
get a pawn to h5 i can also try to put a
queen on b5
sometimes i've even seen white
like castle king side and play c4 maybe
put a rook on c1 and try to open up the
c file so
white's position is very flexible and
the more flexible you can maintain it
usually the more resources you're going
to have
at your disposal so
to me
this is this is one of those key ideas
otherwise the option is
to go c3 right and after c5 just h4 and
after queen c7 you know h5 h6 and just
keep waiting but i don't know who's
going to run out of moves first because
if i don't want to play bishop d3 right
in the chat they're saying just keep the
bishop on f1 and wait for black to go
bishop a6 and take but but how do i
continue here
right because if i make some reckless
moves black might not play bishop a6 but
he might just kick my knight out of e5
maybe knight fd7 maybe knight c6
and then knight d7
although remember with the pawn on h5
you always have this out right so it's
not that serious
but anyway let's see how black punished
me for
for
missing out on this subtlety
right after queen c7 h4
bishop a6
bishop takes
knight takes
and here i didn't play queen e2 right
because i said oh
this this knight looks
looks pretty awful
on a6 right so why would i help chase it
to a better square like c6 or d7
right so that's kind of a
first glance evaluation it's kind of
superficial
and
sure enough after h5
h6 this was pretty much my last chance
to play queen e2 and i didn't take it
here
i just
played g4 and i decided
to go for it
and um and after g4
white's position is is basically busted
so
i want to see if you guys can find uh
the correct approach for black
okay
so so white is basically arguing with g4
that i've got the center on lockdown
right i've got my knight on e5 so the
center is not going to open up
and
that means
i can take some license here to attack
on the king side
so
how can black
make a counter argument to that and say
no that's actually really wrong what you
just said
okay
all right but
let's say i i keep going
right my idea is that if you take
and then take on e5 it looks like you're
you're crushing me here
but
these positions are tricky i have
i have ideas like h6 i have ideas like
rook g1 or knight f3
let's say
i'll start with this move
right
hx is annoying and
even if i don't have an immediate win
i'm probably just going to play like
queen c2 castle queenside you know rook
g3 castles maybe the queen can stay on
e2 just to keep an eye on h5 but once i
castle queenside i go rook g3 and double
up on the g file i mean it's only a
matter of time before black starts
getting into some real trouble
here in in the chat they're suggesting
the move knight e4
which also makes a lot of sense right
preparing f6 but again let's say
let's say i take first
and now i go queenie two right hitting
the knight and maybe preparing to castle
right do you
ignore the knight do you retreat the
knight back to b8 you play f6
i mean if you go knight b8 i might have
a similar idea right i might still be
able to go g5
and if pawn takes
does this work
right takes takes and uh
now i'm
if well if you take i'm just mating you
right here here
and this is checkmate
so
yeah these g5 moves are very dangerous
um
but if not what do you do
i don't know i don't really see that
many good moves for black
another move that's being suggested is
knight h7 now this is something i was
thinking about during the game i was
actually more worried with knight h7
than with knight e4
because it prepares f6 but it also holds
back my g5 idea
[Music]
so here i would have to maybe play
knight f3 to reinforce e5
and here we can see
that the f6 move when there's a pawn on
h5 really doesn't solve all of black's
problems because i can go knight g6 i'm
hitting your rook right if you go bishop
takes f4
i don't know if i maybe i can even do
this
and because i'm attacking the knight as
well right and the bishop so i'm winning
an exchange
at least winning an exchange but i could
even again
say oh
i remember this pawn structure right it
gives me good control over e5 and
pressure on the e file now for example
after rookie eight
uh maybe again i have this g5 move so
white's really rolling at this point all
of white's ideas are
are
coming true
whereas black
not really getting that pawn to e5 right
so
so this is a critical position i would
say what black decides to do next is
very important
yeah this is very tricky
but by the way black's next sequence
is an idea i've never seen before
and after my game
i
became convinced that it's probably one
of the most important thematic ideas for
black
right so
so okay here they're saying c takes d4
right but let's say just go e takes d4
i got my
they picked up on the product placement
ah
you guys you got me
yes that's right knight c5 right so this
is
this is really a key move knight c5
it solves all of black's problems right
the knight that was doing nothing now
joins the game
doesn't just join the game but now
black is creating some concrete threats
like bishop takes bishop takes a knight
d3 check
and
after i played queen e2
how how should black follow up here i
mean how can black really
keep his foot on the gas
well then black takes the knight on e5
right and
and i mean here
do you take on b6 first do you take on
e5 do you retreat the bishop
let's say you go pawn takes just to get
this pawn off your hands
and then you know you take on e5
if i go queen e2 at the very least i
think black could
take on e2 and take on g4 right and he
wins upon
this end game should be winning for
black right because i even have this
weak pawn on h5
black has open files for the rooks
this is just terrible right it's going
to be very similar to what happened in
the game unfortunately
um
so that's a problem right that's the
whole basis of knight c5
so i played queenie two thinking okay i
just defend this knight and then i'm
threatening to take and i thought well
now he
probably gonna go knight d7
and i thought hey you know i'm just
gonna castle
i've got e5 covered
and now i can really focus my attention
on trying to get g5 in
of course this is not what black has in
mind
can you be more specific
knight c to e4 okay
um
and let's say i can i kick your knight
out
right the point is that if knight takes
d2 i can go queen takes d2 and you know
the fireworks are over and it looks like
i'm
more or less keeping things together
black should be okay here i mean for
example if if knight d7 knight d3 this
this was something i considered during
the game
um
but overall i mean white shouldn't be
too
upset
with the way things turned out but i
think black has a much stronger move
here
oops
any ideas
actually um
i kind of gave you a hint
just now
what's what's black's most
important uh
idea right in the london just let's
break it down to to the core principles
because any opening strategy is simply
layers upon layers of a very simple idea
you start with a simple idea and then
you add layers to it right but you
should always be able to trace your
moves back to that sort of original idea
so what is the most basic fundamental
struggle that's going on in the london
yeah the e5 square right so how does
black usually challenge the e5 square
and in fact white has gone through great
pains to make that as unappealing as
possible to black
bingo
so knight f e4 followed by f6
and
black is completely blowing up the
center now
notice that
my g5 idea is
so far remote here like from ever
happening right
this is a devastating situation this is
exactly what white never wants to see
happen
and once again right if if d takes c5
bishop takes e5
this kind of transformation of the
position or change in the pawn structure
is uh is absolutely devastating for
white because the entire queen king side
is um
is in shambles like it reminds me of
some karo khan
positions i don't know if anybody's
familiar with the knight c3 variation of
the kerokan but
basically what black tries to do in that
variation is to provoke white
uh to overextend his position and then
almost every single end game is is a
problem right so
here i'm going to be lucky to even get
to the end game but i'm having you know
serious issues keeping my king side
together
so
so after knight fe4 here i remember
thinking for a long time
and thinking okay
this feels like a key moment
where
it's gonna be like my last chance to
save this game
uh so i have to get this right i can't
i'm already like full count you know
two strikes uh except not full count
because he probably has like no balls or
anything like that so you know he's got
plenty of wiggle room but i'm
i've only got one last
shot here
so
how do i solve this problem right i've
got f6 coming i can't really take on c5
what do we do
what are some candidate moves actually
this is a good place to start right when
you have a complex position in front of
you i mean
look at all the tension that we have
here i mean this can get taken this can
get taken this can get taken this is
coming there's a lot going on here
so this would definitely qualify as a
complex position
and
in order to wrap your head around what's
going on and eventually
arrive at the right move to play you
have to start
by
outlining what your options are right so
and only then
start analyzing comparing them and say
okay this one's better than this one
therefore this one's out right and then
start a sort of process of elimination
so
we already started with d take c5
right
and uh this didn't look too promising
but before we rule it out we need a
better option right you're when you're
playing a chess game
you're not trying to find
a good move you're just trying to find
the best move out of the options that
you have right so you need to be kind of
like a machine in that way you
you shouldn't
have these expectations of what your
position should look like right you
should just be
saying okay i can play these three moves
this one's better than that one okay
this one's out i know those two that are
left which one looks better right and
then you make your move
so
what alternatives do we have to d take
c5
okay knight takes e4 as one of them any
other moves
f3 another one and here in the chat
they're suggesting castle queen side
basically saying actually you're not
threatening anything right
so
so let's take a look at knight takes e4
which is the
only other capture right so obviously
black's gonna go knight takes
and then
it's sort of like
playing a game of ping pong the ball
just came right back now we have to make
another decision
the problem
and the reason
why f6 is a threat is that now having no
pawn on e3 we can't really go knight g6
because our bishop is going to hang
on f4 right so so that's really the
underlying problem that's not allowing
us
to play the way we would normally want
to play as white
so
we need to somehow solve this problem
bishop h2
bishop h2 and if i go f6
f3
all right so we didn't lose anything
that's the good news
but it looks like our pieces are getting
pushed way way back right for example
after bishop takes
what were you going to take with here
the rook or the knight
knight takes
and let's say black
realizes you know his his dream of
playing e5 at the very least this
doesn't feel good right for white i'm
not saying that that white is completely
losing or anything but our king side
looks terrible g5 is off the table black
got to play e5 i mean the opening has
been a disaster
and if you take with the rook i don't i
don't think this is really going to
change things too much right still play
e5 so
you're on to the right idea
but
that's not
the best move to make the most out of
your idea so your idea was i have to
defend this bishop
right so that when f6 comes this knight
can also help to defend this bishop
now
from f4 the knight is going to be able
to defend the bishop right once it goes
to g6
so the question would be is there any
other piece that can come
to aid the bishop by defending it
that way after f6 we can play our normal
move knight g6
yes
queen e3 right and now
after f6 knight g6 the question is well
does black have e5 and the answer is yes
actually black is doing pretty well here
i think after bishop h2 even though
nothing terrible has happened let's say
you know black just sort of
nurtures the position plays rook feat we
can castle i mean white's still alive
here uh i would say maybe black's a
slightly better just because he he won
this tug of war
over the e5 square but the white is very
much still in this game
so that's
a legitimate option i would say right i
mean if now we have something that we
can compare d takes c5 to
and that looks much better than d takes
c5 so i would say okay d takes c5 is out
and
knight takes e4 followed by
by queen e3 looks like a legitimate
option the other move that we were
talking about right was was pawn to f3
now after pawn to f3
what happens if
simply knight takes
i remember during the game
i realized bishop takes is going to end
in disaster right after
bishop takes pawn takes black has queen
takes
and again you see this knight on c5 just
being devastating
this end game should still be losing for
white
even though the structure is a little
bit better than before
yeah so queen takes is kind of force but
after f6 it's funny how black just
doesn't care about d take c5 ever
so
so after knight g6
how would you guys
uh how would you guys play with black
here there's there's a key problem
in this variation that we didn't have in
the previous one
so it's black to play and win
now we can
yeah right again this this knight on c5
is just such a nightmare for us
so so black just wins
so
we see that
if we compare now
knight takes e4 followed by queen e3 to
f3
it seems like knight takes c4 is still
the better choice now here in the chat
they're actually suggesting that this is
not so bad
if white just goes king takes d2 now you
have to be a very brave person
um to even consider king takes d2 but my
question would be like well what happens
if i just do this anyway
right
you would have to take on c5 at this
point
and i would still go
for something like bishop takes e5
right and after
bishop takes maybe f takes and then just
start working on this pawn so again this
is not a position that
inspires a lot of confidence
for white
so okay you know you had knight takes d
take c5 is out
f3 is out
um knight takes e4 seems to be our best
candidate
the last remaining option is castle
queenside
now in the chat they're saying well king
jay z2 might be an ugly
position but it's better than losing a
piece but it's not better than knight
takes e4 followed by queen e3 right so
that's what we're trying to find we're
trying to find something
that's better than knight takes e4
followed by queen e3
because this has really become an
exercise in in calculation right in
in the move selection process so after
castle queenside
what would be
the obvious move for black the obvious
follow-up
right right black wants to play f6
so what's going on here
what do we do
no right knight g6 is pretty much out
because after bishop takes f4
i mean what do you do knight takes maybe
queen takes you don't quite lose a piece
right because you can always take on c5
but
i could maybe just take on f2
and again you know your king sight is
falling apart
right so
and i mean here you can't even take on
b6 right because the queen's hanging you
can't take on f2 because then your rooks
get forked
so things are looking pretty grim here
it looks like you're just going to lose
this pawn next
right
so that's game over
so we can't play our move we can't play
our knight g6
move what else can we play
yeah in the chat they're saying you
pretty much have to take on c5 at this
point
and after bishop takes e5
bishop takes queen takes
there's an important difference
between
this position and all the versions of d
take c5 followed by bishop takes e5 that
we've been looking at
what is that difference why
might this
version
be acceptable for white
this pawn
okay so this pawn is still alive
but how are we going to deal with this
situation here in the center
another good point that's being made is
that after f3 there's there's no queen
g3 check right so the key difference is
that our king is already castled right
we got our king out of the danger
area so
not having to worry about our king's
safety
is
is a huge load lifted from our shoulders
that allows us to focus on other things
now f3
actually
there's a
there's a fundamental problem with f3
tactical one
and um
we've already encountered this idea so
how can black play
knight g3
and
what if i take on e5
and if i go rook g1 it looks like your
knight escapes just in time
but let's say i go
rook
here
trying to go rook g2 next right it looks
like this black knight is a bit off
sides
so that's not it
yeah they got it here in the chat right
this
nasty night on c5
solves all of
well i mean
you could go f takes again opening up
the f file for the rook or you could go
knight d3 knight takes e5 in any case
um black is just going to be winning in
that endgame
so
that's not solving our problems right
we're just losing a pawn
so what can we do
if we go c6 right away like like you
were saying
uh i think this this pawn has its
days numbered right maybe just
knight c5
and eventually just rook c8 rook takes
c6
okay and let's say after pawn takes
take up v6
okay and after pawn takes
king b1
yeah
i mean this looks like maybe white's
okay
it's a little scary to me to open up the
a file like that um
especially if it's not forced right if i
don't have to i would try not to even if
i don't see a clear refutation like
instead of c takes b6
i was thinking
maybe doing something like like the idea
you were mentioning there in the back
right now c6 looks much more interesting
because the knight is gone
and i can play like if you go rook c8
i could go something like queen c4
or maybe
i could start with rookie one saying
okay let's let's trade this one for this
one and i'll keep the a file closed
and if you go f5
you know then i can maybe you know take
go check
and now move my pawn forward and the
pawn is
well supported or at least well enough
by the queen so that if you go something
like rook c8 i can maybe go rook g1 rook
g6
rook d7 all of a sudden you know i have
a plan my pieces are are getting active
so
let's say
if we take this position compared to the
one after knight takes e4 and queen e3
those are are really
uh two remaining options right so we
have to weigh those two and decide which
one we like more so what would you guys
do
yeah right this position looks much
better it looks like you have much more
to look forward to the other one it
seemed like you were just sort of
holding black off but here it seems like
black also needs to be a little bit
careful
so
sure enough
this was uh the right move
right castle queenside
and uh unfortunately this was not the
move that i made
uh in the game
i played
i did play
f3
and after knight takes d2
uh
queen takes d2
my opponent played f6 and here i just
collapsed
i played d take c5
and after bishop takes c takes b6 a
takes b6
and here i realized originally i had
gone into this thinking oh bishop takes
queen takes i can go
queen e2
and this doesn't look that bad
right because
if i trade queens i survived if he goes
queen g3
i think i was just gonna go queen f2
and okay it's nothing to write home
about for white
but the problem was that i didn't
realize how strong f takes e5 was
especially with the open a file because
let's say
i go castle kingside how would you guys
play with black
how would you sketch out
black's next few moves
right this is
this is a problem but this is also very
closely related problem as well right
the backward pawn on f3 but the open
king on g1
yeah so here um there are many ways of
doing this
we have a suggestion in the chat rook a4
followed by rook f4
and then e4
and everything just comes tumbling down
if white stops you from going rook a4
somehow you can also just do rook f4
rook af8 you're going to get the same
position keep it simple so this is just
completely losing for white
that's why i had to go bishop e3
and after bishop g3
i mean i realized i wanted nothing to do
with the king side so
i made a run for it
and played king d1
this was
completely losing
i somehow managed to save this game um
but i really
you know uh it's you'll you'll find this
game in the database if you want to look
for it but it becomes like a pretty
disgusting game from here on out so i'm
going to stop it here because for the
purpose of today's discussion i wanted
to talk about the london system i wanted
to talk about
how
super gns are are looking for subtleties
early on in the game rather than than
engaging in this you know shootout to
see who has a better memory and i think
we made that point so um
i'm gonna stop here uh just for the sake
of my own dignity but um
that's that's pretty much it so uh
thanks guys for for coming and uh for
tuning into the lecture
uh and um we'll be back again next week
all right thank you
[Music]
you